For the purpose of giving students more opportunities to speak Japanese,
we have a Japanese lunch table.
Lunch table is a program called mit Japan.
We have that function of sending language students to
Japan as internships in the summer of 2018,
and together with this mit Japan program, we do
__________ once a week
. Students come to this lunch table.  In
addition to the teacher, native Japanese people,
this is
not only the country of mit Japan,
but there is an eye group called Prince Wipes Club, and they have
received a lot of support from the people of the foreign body club.  In order to increase the
verity of MIT's Japanese language programs
or cultural courses related to the Japanese language on a daily basis,
we usually hold an event called Japanet MIT at
the beginning of each semester.  However,
Japanet mit is more like a party, but what you do at
the event is an overview of the Japanese language program, and then
the courses related to Japanese culture offered at mit,
such as an anime course,
and then Pocker.  There are a variety of courses such as the 2019 course, but
after that, the Vibes club often helps me, but
t cell also introduced my brother, changed kimonos, and coats like
that.  to introduce